you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
a multi-billion pound investment into
the uk's first large-scale gigafactory
including 100 million pledged by the
government
calls for the government to be more
transparent about its net zero strategy
as green targets and the cost of living
crisis divide mps
austria threatens the eu with legal
action over its plans to label gas and
nuclear as sustainable energy
and the warning that the eruption of the
tonga underwater volcano could damage
coral reefs and harm the environment for
years to come
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those coming up with
the solutions
now northumberland could soon benefit
from the construction of a large-scale
gigafactory powering the future of
electric cars in the uk the project is
expected to create up to 8 000 jobs
producing 300 000 electric vehicle
battery packs a year and cost 3.8
billion pounds a hundred million of that
will be funded by the taxpayer the
business secretary quasi quatting told
sky news that it's a once in a
generation opportunity
this is a global competition every other
country advanced manufacturing country
is giving subsidies is giving breaks
to
companies to invest in electric vehicle
manufacturing and this is a once in a
generation opportunity if you haven't
got any ability to make electric
vehicles uh
that you you're never going to build
that and you've got one opportunity to
do that in the early 2020s
well skye's business presenter ian king
has been speaking to the executive
chairman of british vault
this agreement with aberdeen tritax is
very good news for british fault it
brings the business some 1.7 billion
pounds worth of capital in a project
that is likely to cost in total some 3.8
billion pounds now british vault says
it's going to access the remaining
capital either via a stock market
flotation in the fullness of time or by
accessing the debt markets now the
reason that we need these giga factories
built in the united kingdom is because
they are going to be critical for
supporting the british car making
industry as it transitions to electric
vehicles it's been estimated that we
need something like 90 gigawatts hours
of capacity per year if the british car
industry is to have a sustainable future
that means around eight sites in total
we currently have some two gigawatt
hours worth a year of battery making
capacity so the race is on to build more
now british vault says that once it's up
and running it should be able to
offer around 30 gigawatt hours worth of
capacity on its own other sites that
have been talked about include one in
the west midlands close to coventry
airport and one in somerset but as i say
around eight of these are going to be
required in total well earlier on i
spoke to peter rolton he's the executive
chairman of british vault here's what he
told me the challenge really is is uh
the sites are difficult to find
i mean we've got 230 acres there in in
southeast northumberland um you need a
huge grid connection the because the uh
manufacturing process lithium-ion
batteries is very very energy intense um
they're not the sort of things you need
to bring together to get a good site and
not very readily available and of course
land price in the uk is a big challenge
as well because you know employment land
in say the midlands and south east you
know is typically now a million pounds
an acre
we bought the entire 230 acres in the
northeast for four million pounds so you
can see that you really have to sort of
pick and choose your locations to make
these things work
now you might remember that earlier in
the week we brought you the story that's
rumbling on of divisions within the
government
over its net zero targets well as
inflation rises and the cost of living
crisis casts a dark cloud over many uk
households there are concerns that
keeping energy bills down will impact
the green agenda
and today the labour party has
questioned the credibility of the net
zero strategy after it refused to
publish details of its climate policy
saying that ministers need to be open
with the public skies hannah thomas
peter has been speaking to conservative
mps and business owners worried about
the consequences of rising prices
harvey's brewery in louis sussex where
head brewer miles jenner is busy finding
the cash to pay for rising bills and
invest in going green
the government's target for net zero
emissions by 2050 in his view a crucial
one
can you imagine
this being a net zero operation
i can dream
that is a goal which seems utopian but
one well worth aspiring to so it's a
price you're willing to pay
i think it's it's a price that
we all have to pay but some are worried
better insulation heat pumps electric
cars hard to afford amid a cost of
living crisis farmers don't make much
money as it is let alone with an extra
forking out of however much it's going
to be to change it all as a small
business owner it's going to be very
difficult to find funds
some of these flats and houses need
me doing
and you just haven't got the money to do
it with
the government has promised support for
households and businesses to decarbonize
but it cannot possibly pay for
everything
the government's office for budget
responsibility has estimated that the
total cost of net zero
could be nearly one and a half trillion
pounds and that although that will
deliver eventually huge savings an awful
lot of the spending will have to happen
in the next decade
now the issue is emerging as a divide
within the conservative party
on the one side a net zero scrutiny
group of around 20 mps organized by
brexiteer and serial rebel steve baker i
genuinely believe that when the full
costs of net zero start hitting us if
people have never been given a choice at
the ballot box
we could end up with something bigger
than the poll tax certainly bigger than
brexit because the numbers of people hit
by it and their inability to cope will
be huge
not so says the conservative environment
network
net zero is not just about
going green it is about actually
supporting jobs for the you know for the
future actually creating an entirely new
economy it will be painful and difficult
but we don't as a result have a reaction
that throws it entirely
out of the window
a defining opportunity or a fracture
that will not heal
for the moment at least
the future of the green revolution is
not a certain one hannah thomas peter
sky news
we can get more reaction now on the
government's net zero strategy joining
me now is jamie peters the director of
campaigns at friends of the earth jamie
good to see you this evening you think
that people
who could be faced with struggling to
put food on the table will still be
happy to pay towards net zero
well it's absolutely not fair to expect
the average household to fit the bill
through higher taxes and that's not
what's going to happen it's not what
anyone's calling for but it's worth
exposing a bit of a math here the energy
prices they're not going up because of
clean energy or climate policies they're
going up because of a wholesale gas
increase that's what 90 percent of the
energy price is because gas is an
international and volatile market what
we need to do is increase renewables to
make sure we're not relying on gas in
the first place and insulate homes which
reduces demand and makes bills cheaper
so there's some win-win policies that we
should be doing right now
but jamie
green levies constitute something like
15
to energy bills at the moment and the
government could do away with them at a
stroke
so let's be very clear energy prices
have gone up because the international
gas market fossil fuel market and prices
are going up
and let's be clear on another thing
accident climate change is the right
thing to do for communities across the
country does it lead to new jobs lower
bills if they're done right everyone can
have a warm home that's affordable if
these policies are done correctly and
it's the right thing to do for the
economy is the fossil fuel industries on
its way out is dying and finally it's
the right thing to do morally
overwhelming majority of people in this
country want the uk to be a climate
leader and it has to be
well now let's show you our data
dashboard for a moment here you can see
great britain's real-time power mix and
it's showing us that gas is currently
making up 52.3
coal coming in at 2.4 percent and
renewables of course like wind and solar
coming in at 21
and this number here this nuclear that
is making up for
11.7 percent of the power mix here right
now and staying with that nuclear theme
a row is erupting in the european union
over the use of nuclear as a sustainable
energy source austria's climate minister
has warned the country will take legal
action if the european commission
proceeds with its plan to label gas and
nuclear as sustainable the commission's
proposals would grant gas plants a green
label until 2030 that's if they meet
criteria including an emissions limit eu
energy ministers have been meeting to
discuss prices energy efficiency and
plans for labeling green investments
and the government could be bringing in
increased background checks for waste
firms and mandatory digital tracking of
rubbish in an effort to curb serious and
organized crime new powers in the
environment act will require companies
handling waste to keep a record of when
it's produced to when it's disposed of
recycled or reused nearly 1 000 illegal
waste sites each year are already being
shut down by the environment agency
according to the government
and the world rally championship has got
underway in monaco and this year the
competition has adopted hybrid cars as
well as housing a 3.6 kilowatt hour
battery the new plug-in hybrid cars are
also running on 100
sustainable fuel
now scientists are warning that the
volcanic eruption in tonga could create
long-lasting environmental and economic
damage threatening coral reefs eroding
coastlines and disrupting fisheries
skies correspondent greg milan reports
now from fiji
well the islands of tonga were already
particularly vulnerable to the effects
of climate change and the volcanic
eruption has highlighted those risks in
a real and very alarming way first of
all of course increasing temperatures
means higher sea levels and you put
tsunami waves and a storm surge on those
higher sea levels two inches per year
they estimate around tonga you can see
how they would be
more destructive there are other factors
as well tsunami waves cause coastal
erosion
they damage the coral reefs and
mangroves that help ease the effects of
of rising uh sea levels salt water
coming ashore can damage agricultural
soil and that damage can can last for
years
the gases often that are released in an
eruption cause acid rain and you think
how much tonga relies on its waters for
food and for livelihoods that can be a
significant impact the ash that is all
over those islands
isn't really an issue so far most of the
soil on tonga is volcanic in nature uh
anyway but sometimes uh the scientists
say you can rely on a volcanic eruption
to actually cool
the earth by putting up sulfur dioxide
into the stratosphere they say this one
didn't really last long enough uh to
make a difference so no help
from nature there already they say that
the tongans are likely to be the first
wave of climate refugees in the world
and they believe what's happened over
the last week has simply hastened that
process
stay with us coming up after the break
we'll be discussing the government's net
zero commitments i'll be joined by
climate justice activist michaela loach
and chairman and founding director of
climate change think tank e3g
tom burke
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with climate
justice activist michaela loach and
founding director of climate change
think tank e3g tom burke good to see you
both this evening now the prime
minister's loss of authority and
potential loss of office is an open
invitation to candidates to succeed him
to seek support by abandoning his high
profile green
policies now i'm hoping you might
recognize those words tom because
you wrote them how big a problem would
you say is the current political theater
for the green agenda now in the uk
i think it's a real problem on two
counts one because the prime minister
has made it such a signature issue for
him
then it becomes an obvious target as
i've said for those people who want to
succeed in him but that creates an
uncertainty which also undermines the
willingness of investors to invest in
driving us forward on the way to a clean
and green society that we i think want
to build so it has it has two impacts uh
really on us
and michaela the pm's big showpiece of
course was cop 26 not so long ago in
glasgow once the world's media all
packed up and went home would you say it
achieved anything other than what greta
tunberg would call blah blah blah
so i think that i can't say that cop
achieved nothing at all but i do think
that it was more of a press conference
for world governments to make themselves
seem like they're doing more on climate
than they actually are and i think that
we haven't actually seen kind of the
ambition that was talked about by this
government followed through afterwards
and boris johnson might talk a lot about
climate and say that it's a big priority
but actually in action um uk government
is still promoting fossil fuel
production in the uk is still approving
new oil fields in the uk which is
ridiculous and also its tax regime
actually is hugely beneficial for these
oil companies that actually means that
the uk in the north sea is the most
profitable country in the world to
extract oil and gas which is completely
like not compatible with any sort of
climate leadership so i would be kind of
cautious and to make out that boy
johnson is a great climate leader um
given all of that
let's come back to the weakened
political capital of of the pm if we may
there was a quote in that report from
steve baker conservative mp he says i
genuinely believe that when the full
costs of net zero start hitting us if
people have never been given a choice at
the ballot box we could end up with
something bigger than the poll tax
certainly bigger than brexit because the
numbers of people hit by it and their
inability to cope will be
huge is there a democratic deficit with
all of this push to net zero tom would
you say
no there's not and uh steve baker is
one out of touch with what most people
and we've seen enormous amount of
evidence both directly and what people
do and also uh in polling that people
want to get on with dealing with climate
change but also this is a man who is
opposed to green levees but on uh monday
he voted in favor of a green level we
haven't got and actually don't need so
in order to support nuclear power so i'm
not sure i'm going to use steve baker as
an indicator of what the british public
are going to uh want to do
okay your opinion coming through pretty
loud and clear there tom michaela we've
got a pandemic to pay for we were still
paying for the financial crisis and now
we need to pay for net zero do we just
need a mindset shift that the days of
the uk as being a relatively low tax
country need to change
i think when we're talking about how
much money we have for things like to
pay for the pandemic or everything else
we need to also remember that the uk
government has paid huge amounts of
public money to oil and gas companies so
the same companies that are polluting so
much and the same companies that are
paying out their shareholders in
billions so since signing the paris
agreement um the uk government has paid
400 billion pounds of public money to um
shell alone and shell in that same time
as paid 45 billion to their shareholders
so actually there's a huge amount of
public money that's going in the wrong
direction it's promoting the polluters
and if we instead redirected those funds
towards a just transition towards
funding net zero so it's not being paid
for by ordinary people but instead um by
our like our funds that are meant for
all of us and by and the companies that
are actually causing the most harm so
the companies that are causing harm
shouldn't be um being paid out loads of
money and in public payments they should
be taxed um rightfully and fairly and
because they should be the ones funding
this transition not ordinary people a
trust transition tom do you think that
is anywhere on the government's agenda
i'm not sure it's on the government's
agenda at the moment i was just going to
say where uh michaela is absolutely
right if the government uh had not
abandoned green levees in uh the uh last
uh in the cameron years we'd now be uh
consumers in this country now be saying
about two and a half billion less than
they're currently paying so it really is
as michaela says it's a question of who
pays uh for this and right now there's
an obvious answer if you want to help
with the immediate short term problem
caused by the grass prices then what you
could do is tax some of those uh very
large profits additional profits that
are going to the uh oil and gas
companies and use that to increase
universal benefit as we did during the
lockdown to those people who are most
disadvantaged and create a real peaceful
just transition but that's a thing that
we'll have to see whether the government
takes that opportunity or not
yeah well we're going to be debating
this aren't we time and time again over
the coming months a bit of a if you
excuse the pan or handbrake turn here
motorsport and sustainability aren't two
words you often see side by side but its
governing body is trying to change that
first formula e then extreme e and now
the world rally championship has taken
steps to reduce their carbon footprint
with hybrid cars and sustainable fuel
now we'll progress to cleaner
alternatives inspirates fans to make
those sustainable changes what do you
reckon michaela is it a gimmick or a
significant step
so i think we need to be talking about
climate in all sorts of spaces i
am not someone who watches most sports
um so i'm not as aware of kind of that
whole sphere um but i think it's good
that all those conversations are
happening and starting because we can
leapfrog from there to
how do we actually make um our transport
systems more sustainable so um i think
that rather than it being kind of about
these techie solutions that maybe seem
really exciting it's about talking about
like public transport as well and like
our transportation systems and and
making those greener and also focusing
on those rather than just individualized
electric vehicles because we even saw
earlier in the program people talking
about their fears around having to buy
things like electric cars that can seem
expensive um well how about instead we
have public transport that is affordable
for everyone is accessible for everyone
um and that everyone can actually use
and focus on that more than the things
that seem like flash inexpensive but i
mean it's good that these kind of spaces
that might not be normally climate
spaces are starting these conversations
um as it's a good way that we can talk
about these other things tom has
michaela just hit it on the head there
and do we do too much fetishization of
of cars and really we should just be
viewing them as a mode of transport a
utility essentially and only when we've
had that mindset shift can we start to
move towards net zero
i think i think she has hit it on that
on the head and i think we shouldn't
expect all change to be heroic they're
going to be marginal changes and it's
good to see the motor industry and
particularly the motor racing industry
seeing that it has a part to play and
it's making marginal change won't save
the world on its own but what i think is
really interesting is it will get a
whole lot of people who don't normally
spend very much time talking about
climate change talking about it and
that's a good thing yeah uh even uh we
don't know much about cars but we're
talking about cars and sustainability
michaela final question um
about sustainable fuel
why are we even talking about that
shouldn't we just be talking about going
from combustion engines to electric
yeah i think that's interesting and i
think that there's there's a lot of time
i think there's this kind of yeah i
guess you said before
festivalization of these like newer
things and these heroic kind of seeming
things um and this new tech um i think
that we it'd be great if we focused a
lot on the things we already have now
and making those practical practicable
and allowing other people to access them
and rather than focusing so much on
these things that don't exist yet but i
think that there is also a space for us
to be exploring as many students as
possible but remembering that we
actually have loads of solutions right
now that we could be implementing and
maybe thinking about how can we
implement those solutions rather than
just looking out for other places okay
well we could go on all evening but i do
need to draw it to a close there as
we're out of time but michaela loch
tomberg always good to speak to you
thank you very much for joining us on
sky news this evening
thank you
now before we go remember you can still
download climate cast wherever you get
your podcasts this week katarina
vertotsi is in manchester where plans to
tackle air pollution have become unstuck
that's after a local backlash from local
businesses who say it'll be them who has
to pay for it all now thank you for
watching the daily climate show hope to
see you next time